phrase all lives matter was derived from
black lives matter to subvert black
lives matter and I won't come here and
sit down and say that that's okay and I
have a law enforcement go to the left
pool of light by my blacklivesmatter
supporters go to the right pool of light
I regularly fear for my life you know
I'm an armed patrol officer so I do
respond to burglar alarms so if someone
breaks into someone's house have a gun I
would have to respond to that certain
situation I do fear for my life in a way
I guess you can say I do something that
I think every black man every black
person in this country many people of
color I've been trained to do and that's
when a law enforcement officer gets
behind me and I'm driving I'm making
sure I'm signaling I'm checking my speed
I'm thinking of all the different
legitimate ways that you could stop me
and in that moment I recognized and I
realized that I'm not a scholar with a
bachelor's in political science a
bachelor's in sociology a master's in
public policy in that moment I'm just
another black man to that officer and
that scares me
I may be could have stepped forward I
feel scared for my life when I'm at work
often when you get pulled over and all
the thoughts and things that are going
through your mind or where when I pull a
car over I'm thinking about where I'm at
on the highway how I'm gonna pull this
vehicle over did I run the plate did it
come back to that vehicle am i buckled
in am i not buckled in because most
officers are shot and killed during
traffic stops and as I approach I put my
hand on that car to leave my handprint
because if I'm shot and killed that
person is further incriminated by the
evidence of my prints being on their car
but I don't feel afraid for my life as a
citizen about at work I definitely do
and that's a choice I made I choose not
to live in fear if the question was do I
feel less safe now than I did five years
ago
I would say yes and I think that that's
because we have rampant social chaos
that's expanding and I think that that's
playing a large role and a lot of the
trends that we're seeing what do you
mean by social chaos out of wedlock
birth rates statistically you know that
set to child back five times more likely
to be poor and nine times more likely to
drop out of school and 20 times more
likely to end up in prison I mean the
caste that I'm seeing more recently is
white men walking into schools with
ar-15s and slaughtering people yeah and
then as well and that is what you're
seeing and what you're not seeing is the
dozens of homicides that occur in
Chicago on a daily basis and that speaks
to certainly a media that's desirous to
push an agenda and a narrative that
factually doesn't bear out there is a
massive disparity between black crime
and white crime and large and obviously
that's going to lead to accelerated
interactions with law enforcement this
the criminalization of black people when
you have more police officers patrolling
a concentrated area then of course you
have more stops you have more you know
situations where police officers say oh
they did
signal and then when I pulled them over
I pulled all occupants out of the car I
searched the car I found this gun
allegedly buried somewhere and all of a
sudden now you have a crime as a public
defender the the reputation is that you
know I'm going to lose most of my cases
I have one far more cases than I have
lost my name is Alisa Blair I am African
American I'm also a criminal defense
attorney as a public defender I've seen
the mistreatment of my clients I see the
disproportionate incarceration of black
and brown people and I see the excessive
force used in arrests police should be
given more resources I think police
should definitely be given more
resources so that they have other
options besides killing people officers
should have the resources available to
them to handle a situation without
casualties on either side yeah I mean as
an officer I appreciate hearing that
from a member of the public and from a
public defender and can speak to it for
myself and my department and what I've
seen in other departments in the area
and know that we need more resources and
different types of training
communication techniques to de-escalate
situations and different types of least
force option techniques but as a small
woman I also want to be able to
physically protect myself and it's it's
a hard balance the largest expense for
almost every municipality and county is
Public Safety there's plenty of money
but we don't have is enough implicit
bias training the things that we carry
about ourselves that define how we
interpret who we're interacting with by
judgement we don't have enough
contextualizing of the communities that
you're serving draw officers from the
communities from which they serve that
way when they go back and their policing
their own community that's deeper than
just the race of the officers so you
think that black police officers need to
be trained to be more sensitive to the
ball
community is that what you're saying no
I think black officers that are policing
black community should come from those
communities and I think a white officer
who comes from that community might even
be more effective than a black officer
from somewhere else I agree and I think
I think that that's a great point which
is that an officer a white officer a
black officer a female officer a spanic
officer could be just as good as any
other or better and that's because there
are things other than skin color and I
think that what's so concerning about
this dialogue is that it is pushing us
further back into black communities
white communities when really I thought
that the goal of Martin Luther King was
that we're gonna be moving to a society
where we were being judged by the
content of her character if we keep
moving further into identifying based on
our groups I think that we're doing a
disservice to his message which I think
was very powerful and that United the
country in many ways but not at the time
in Martin Luther King's time why folks
hated him it causes me to bristle and
and have an emotional reaction whenever
somebody says you know black people are
killing folks 50% in violent crimes and
then says Martin Luther King United the
country Martin Luther King would be down
for black lives matter the next
statement is I believe that all lives
matter
it's a little bit surprising below all
of this stuff below skin deeper than all
this there is a intrinsic god-given life
that's put inside of all of us I think
that it's concerning that any movement
would reject the fundamental premise of
that while preaching for equality
exactly at that point you're really not
an equality movement if you're really
only interested in speaking to your
specific group I truly believe in I
agree with everything that you say
everyone deserves life and I believe
that you know life is a gift
plain and simple all life yes all life
matters all life deserves a chance yeah
I think that especially in this platform
but also in the world in the country
that we live in today stating that all
lives matter takes away from the
inequality that's happening in the world
of course all lives matter it negates
the fact that something has to be
addressed and if you don't address it
and you don't recognize that there is a
problem that has to be changed then you
never [ __ ] change that's not our
intention our attention was just an
answer a simple question but it's not
what not everything is the same do all
lives matter
if you ask me if all lives have
intrinsic value if all lives are
valuable if all lives are worthy I would
have said hell yes and would have been
the first one in my chair all lives
matter is a specific phrase similar to
blue lives matter and anything else that
mattered after black lives were
exclaiming to have mattered to detract
to appropriate to subvert the message in
the framing and the narrative that's
being brought to us by the black lives
matter movement so I don't think anybody
here in this room thinks that any life
is less worthy than another's but the
phrase all lives matter was derived from
black lives matter to subvert black
lives matter and I won't come here and
sit down and say that that's okay I mean
I feel like we're just kind of going
into the weeds here question wasn't a
black lives matter it was a simple
question do you believe that all lives
matter
that's an interesting phrase connotation
meta phrase that you might
I think work I think not really I think
that you can attach whatever you want
right now that's a thing I try and step
back from you know whatever sort of
identity political stuff we have going
on and I try and deal with things
head-on based on reality when someone
says to me do you think all lives matter
I answer unequivocably yes every time
the same way if you ask me a black lives
matter or female lives matter I will
answer the same way do black lives
matter yes they do
I had conflicting feelings about coming
here today for me I was conflicted
because I I don't feel like I should
speak for POC oppression but as a white
woman I think that I can be of value to
other white people who may not
understand I'm Sandra cruising well I'm
from the 60s and I went to jail a lot
for fighting for women's rights and as a
human being I think it's important that
I speak out and speak up foreign
justices I'm feeling conflicted now as
someone who steps into the law
enforcement side as if we are on
opposite sides I am a law enforcement
officer and a black lives matter
supporter I find myself searching for
what to do and how to make a difference
and I've had moments of thinking about
leaving the force I finally had a
realization that this gives me an
opportunity to have a different angle as
a white woman and also as a police
officer to potentially make a difference
even if it's just with changing myself I
didn't hesitate I've been a civilian my
entire life and I consider it an honor
to have an opportunity to provide voice
for a law enforcement and the men and
women that serve our communities I think
it's fundamentally important for a
society to respect law enforcement men
and women that serve our communities
with tremendous honor and distinction
end up getting a bad rap and I think
that that's very harmful I think that it
is important I think it's imperative
to speak whenever you have an
opportunity to and I think that all of
us in whatever movements were part of or
whatever belief systems were part of
should use our gifts
you know de-escalation training is
sitting in a room like this with a
PowerPoint and walking officers through
scenarios and nothing nothing in a
scenario is ever going to be like the
real world in defense of officers like
only those of us that walk in the shoes
of having a badge and a gun and being in
these high-stress situations can really
articulate what it's like to make these
split-second decisions with our training
officers need to be in these types of
discussions owning their [ __ ] and being
like I did this wrong and I have this
prejudice and how can I sit with people
who can teach me and change me this is
what I think is sort of dangerous about
a conversation like this is that really
the only thing that I want law
enforcement being trained on is the law
okay there's nebulous conversation about
thinking about how I think about things
and so message the enforcement think of
ourselves as social workers with a gun
and that's concerning because your job
is to enforce the law as someone in the
field who wants more de-escalation
training it's not because I don't
believe in a lot of the laws that I
enforce and it is my job to enforce the
law I'm not a law warning officer that's
not what I signed up to do but we are
given the discretion to make choices and
that's why we need more training because
we're human beings just in my
perspective and I appreciate your
support of law enforcement and your
perspective yeah and I appreciate your
perspective as well as your your real
service that you've done so and I don't
want it our disagreement certainly don't
take away from my respect and admiration
for your service thank you thank y'all
respect the service of everyone who
works to the service of others I don't
think anybody in this room is against
individual officers the conversation is
to take a step back and recognize that
this institution is a relic of
anglo policing from european culture but
also slave catching and deep-rooted
racism in American policy and we need to
take that step back and re Center this
conversation on the fact that it's
bigger than just an officer I think part
of the problem is that we're still so
segregated where do we go to have these
conversations where do we go to learn
from each other to break down the
stereotypes it's systemic and I am so
thrilled that there's a black lives
matter movement it's really exciting
guys thank you so much I know this
hasn't been an easy one but I appreciate
your time
feel free to continue the discussion if
you'd like outside it's a pleasure I
really appreciate you speaking your
truth and hearing mine as well I really
appreciate all of you guys hey guys I'm
Jason and I'm Dan and we just want say
thank you once again for watching
another episode of middle ground as
always let us know in the comments what
you think we want to get into these
issues we want to be able to heal
divides well be able to cross boundaries
and also let us know what you think
future episodes should be about click
here to subscribe to more videos click
here to watch more videos